my name's barry starr and i'm the
director of outreach activities at
stanford university in the department of
genetics
through that i also do a lot of work
with the tech museum which is a science
museum a hands-on science museum in san
jose i love genetics because it
is such an important part of who we are
it's not the whole story obviously
environment plays a big role too but
it's really the genetic blueprint for
who we are and we can learn so much
about human history what our ancestors
looked like we can get rid of issues of
race and that sort of thing because you
can see in genetics that we're all
basically the same genetics is this
wonderful interesting fascinating
subject that everyone should be excited
about
and many people are not because they get
bogged down in vocabulary in examples
they don't understand things like that
so my hope is that by the lectures that
i'm giving
that you can see some of the really
interesting and fun stuff you can get
for out of genetics for someone who's
just starting out in genetics i'd say
go for it don't be intimidated just have
a good time enjoy it
you